what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar back at it again to talk about
one piece and wow
this chapter was full of great moments
and one of the craziest cliffhangers so
make sure to stay tuned for this one if
you do enjoy seeing these weekly
one-piece reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing you could do is
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and if
you're new to the space fam let me know
by saying hi in the comments
lastly while you wait for the next
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist that
includes videos on all the yonko
warlords revolutionaries and much more
link to that
is in the description now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all
so this chapter is called demonio which
google translates as spanish for devil
which seems to refer to robin obviously
the devil child who was in the middle of
her battle with black maria
last chapter another flying six member
who are recently
dropping like flies one drake switched
sides two and three page one and ulti
were defeated with some help from big
mom
four frankie beat sasuke five jimbei
beat who's who
and now they really think about it 6
black maria is the only one left to beat
crazy to think how far the straw hats
have come where most members can take
out someone as strong as a flying six
member
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
robin hasn't defeated black maria yet as
this chapter starts you gotta love robin
and her beautiful self
she bloomed a big version of herself to
match black maria's big size and uses
sea serpent
a move where her giant arms flail about
and grab maria the problem is though
maria attacks the giant arms which in
turn
hurts robin as well it's a double-edged
sword as maria points out because
although
this gives rob in greater reach and
coverage she becomes a bigger target
too including to maria's poison tipped
spider legs
maria uses webs to trap all of robin's
giant arms
leaving the beautiful giant robin wide
open for an attack
we get an interesting moment where maria
puts on brass knuckles and says she's a
martial artist at heart
not something i expected from someone
who often uses a weapon and has
all those spider tricks up her sleeves
but an interesting development
nonetheless
she just jumps in there and starts
beating on giant robin
saying there's no need to hold back
since they are both women
you can tell she's really enjoying
herself here and again it's shown how in
one piece female characters can be just
as ruthless and skilled in fighting as
male characters
this is nothing new for one piece since
we have a female yonko
after all but still it's notable maria
even calls the giant robin
a satisfyingly large punching bag and
you see robin's human body in pain from
all the hits
this is no downplayed fight and i really
appreciate that it might even be my
favorite flying six fight
yet which is saying a lot the tables
have clearly turned though and
robin de-blooms her giant body while
maria comments on how she's now the one
trying to get away
robin tries to grab her or hit her with
some giant arms but maria skillfully
blocks them and traps them with her
spider webs
not only that though she then reveals
that the webs are flammable and lights
them on fire from the looks of it maria
has the clear advantage right now
and as people do when they get
overconfident and think they're gonna
win
she starts trash talking she starts
talking about how robin said it would be
over quickly
and now she's losing she talks about
what a disgrace sanji is again
and says that this defeat proves what a
hopeless pair they are
i'm sure sanji would love to hear that
he's being paired up with robin here but
the point is
one last time maria is emphasizing all
of robin's potential insecurities
robin is now trapped by webs and the
fire is everywhere to a large extent
preventing new limbs from blooming
because they would just burn up and hurt
robin maria
asks why the giant skeleton yokai a
fitting description for
brooke in wano doesn't help her but
again brooke just laughs it off calling
her moronic
all the straw hats don't see robin as a
damsel in distress in need of saving
and that's not because they don't care
about her as maria keeps emphasizing but
because they trust and rely on her and
they don't want to disrespect her by not
trusting in her abilities
maria keeps hitting robin saying what is
the devil child gonna do
now she's helpless dead weight for her
crew and they only value her mind so she
doesn't even need her limbs
since no one needs her help and there's
the big thing people feel good when
they're needed by others and to robin
someone who has struggled to feel worthy
and find meaning in life
sanji and brook trusting in her to help
them
is the greatest gift that's what anakima
is relying on each other and knowing you
can't do everything on your own
luffy is not a super saiyan god ultimate
without his crew and friends he would
have lost most of his battles in one
piece
another interesting thing is that maria
says they only value her mind which in
and of itself to me
is not a huge insult even if robin
wasn't a fighter she'd still be an asset
because of her knowledge
and that's not really an insult in and
of itself of course beyond that she's
also a terrific fighter and obviously
the crew doesn't just view her as a
brain
just as they don't just view zorro as a
sword they view her as family
as an irreplaceable part of their nakama
we then get a flashback of robin with
the revolutionaries and this seems like
a good time to plug my most recent one
piece video about monkey d
dragon his commanders and their powers
explained link to that is in the
description definitely check it out when
you finish this video but for the
purpose of this chapter
the revolutionaries are teaching her not
to just slap but how to do a powerful
palm strike
i kind of wish she became an expert in
dragon claw fists like
sabo but at least she does agree to
learn the fishman karate palm thing as
she calls it i love seeing koala and
sabo so happy when she agrees to learn
it and it's definitely a good thing she
did
she already used it in the past to help
the crew as we see her using it from the
ship
sabo explains that she's gotta hone in
on the opponent's core
and that this move will be her trump
card she ends up using the secret
fishman karate move with a giant arm and
maria thinks she missed but
no actually she took down the ceiling
stopping the fire
i love those next level chest like moves
and then we see
something truly crazy and epic robin
looking very fine adopts the look of a
devil
in this form called demonial fleur
she says she'll be the devil if that's
what it takes to help the people
counting on her
such an epic moment and i love seeing
black maria horrified
at the sight of r straw hat clearly
maria has become the prey here
robin even brings back what maria was
saying to her
that this time maria shouldn't have
limbs and then in this amazing panel
she uses her new form in advanced
dislocation techniques to completely
wreck black maria i cannot wipe the
smile off my
face this was such an amazing moment i
love the look
i love the vampire teeth and wings
robin's got going on here and it's
significant that she's not calling
herself
a devil child but a devil as if she's
fully grown
and become a full-fledged devil one that
obviously you don't want to mess with
what a moment for robin it's one of my
favorite moments of hers not only
because she beats a flying six member
but because of the progression of her
character arc
and the form and the great dialogue
taking place and it's official
i can't decide between robin and nami i
feel like i alternate every single time
between which one i like more depending
on who gets the most recent epic moment
i'll just have to accept that i can't
choose between these two
gorgeous girls so after that glorious
battle the maria underlings can't enter
because the ice walls that brook created
and as they peek between the walls to
see maria defeated and robin looking
like a demon
brook takes advantage of the fact that
they are all lined up and hits them with
an
orchestra finishing the force off we see
robin saying she overdid it a bit and
falling down as brook comes in
saying easy there robin a very
heartwarming moment and
wow robin could not have been cooler in
that fight she gets mvp for this chapter
for sure we then get caribou who is
using his swamp powers to take out a
month's worth of food
on an attempt to get luffy back to 100
and luffy is looking better really going
to town on the food
we get a hilarious moment where they're
asking if luffy can explain the
situation
and he speaks as he's eating and all
that comes across
is traff munch munch choo choo whoop
kaido and that's pretty much it it's
absolutely hilarious
and then perhaps the most interesting
thing this chapter
happens which is a big statement after
robin's amazing performance
but i think it is warranted momo and
shinobu are talking shinobu is
overprotective but momo insists that
they must do
all they can and specifically he must do
all he can to defend the capital
and stop it from being destroyed in
order to do that not only does momo have
to go back
he wants shinobu to use her ripe ripe
fruit to turn him into an
adult he'll still have the mind and
heart of a child
and he'll never be able to return to
normal but momo doesn't care he needs
access to a more powerful version of
himself
and the more powerful dragon that it
would result in
we're told on the side of the final
panel that momo is showing such
unwavering resolve he's crying but
determined to do
anything he can to help his country a
true leader worthy of being the son of
odin this
is an amazing turning point and if it
wasn't for robin's epicness this chapter
i'd give the mvp to momo for his resolve
alone
this is gonna be crazy now that it's
been mentioned it's pretty much
guaranteed to happen and since momo has
a clone of quite possibly the strongest
fruit
he'll be insanely useful once he becomes
an adult although i'm not saying this
will happen shinobu can
in theory use the fruit on luffy if
needed to give him a power boost too
the possibilities here are really
endless and i can't wait to see momo
become the legend he's so clearly meant
to be
but wow guys what insanity what epicness
what all-around mind-blowing moments and
reveals one piece is fire
and that's nothing new but i always
gotta make it clear just how good it is
in my humble opinion 1021 chapters in
and i'm still on the edge of my seat
looking forward to the next chapter
as usual let me know your thoughts on
this one what you're looking forward to
happening next the most and let me know
who your mvp was this round the very
attractive robin
the cool brook the swamp fridge caribou
or
the resolve dragon momo plenty of
choices to choose from even that one guy
who talks a lot this chapter while he's
eating so no one understands him
but yeah if you did enjoy this review
and want to keep them coming
the best thing you could do is channel
the pirate king within and smash
that like button until it changes colors
sometimes it changes to black
white blue whatever it is smash that
thing if you haven't make this the video
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future one piece videos that's
just the way it works and if you are new
to the space fan let me know by saying
hi
in the comments so glad to have you
aboard lastly while you wait for the
next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist that includes videos on
the yonko
warlords revolutionaries and much more
link to that is in the description
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you